there's a new report estimating what
portion of Donald Trump's tariffs were
paid by Americans and I'm not going to
keep you in suspense I'll tell you right
away
the number is 100% 100% of Donald
Trump's tariffs were paid by Americans
and if this is shocking to you you
either weren't paying attention or don't
understand how tariffs work because
we've been sounding the alarm about this
since the day that Donald Trump started
talking about putting these tariffs on
China it doesn't matter how many times
Donald Trump says China pays the tariffs
China does not pay the tariffs here's
one example from just a few days ago
repeating it doesn't make it any more
true Donald Trump tweeting quote the
United States Treasury has taken in many
billions of dollars from the tariffs we
are charging China and other countries
that have not treated us fairly in the
meantime we are doing well in various
trade negotiations capitalizing tea and
trade and and in negotiations currently
going on at some point this had to be
done the Treasury has taken in the money
that part is true but the money is not
coming from China
we are not china charging China anything
a working paper by economists at the
Federal Reserve Bank of New York as well
as a Columbia professor David Weinstein
and Princeton's Stephen reading
determined that approximately 100
percent of the Trump administration's
tariffs have been paid by US by
Americans let's explain if Chinese steel
costs $20 per square foot okay and
Donald Trump puts a 10% tariff on
Chinese steel an American company still
pays China their $20 per square foot and
then they give $2 per square foot that
10% tariff to the United States Treasury
what did China pay nothing China still
got their $20 per square foot the
American company pays for it not China
not China how many times do we have to
say this and then if you're an American
building a house for example and you
have a house that's partially made of
steel the fact that your builder paid a
10% tariff on the steel gets passed
along to you to the end-user if you're
buying a car that uses steel the car
will be bumped up in cost by the
manufacturer to account for the fact
that they have paid the tariff we pay
for it not the Chinese I imagine Donald
Trump has this mental image of Chinese
billionaires sitting around writing
checks to the United States for his
tariffs when it's really just
middle-class families here in the United
States that end up paying more for stuff
their house their car whatever products
from China does Donald Trump not
understand this or is he understanding
it but he's choosing to lie and to gas
light because he knows the truth is
actually really bad the headline should
not be Americans pay 100% of tariffs the
headline should be people are so
clueless about tariffs that it is
newsworthy that Americans are paying
100% of the tariffs this is less about
people being uneducated than it is about
people being deliberately miss educated
because a lot of people did look into
this they researched they're not fake
news sources and they were given an
incorrect explanation that agreed with
what Donald Trump is saying publicly so
maybe research is a bit of a stretch but
people you know they checked what their
cousin posted on Facebook it's they sort
of tried and there was a huge
disinformation campaign around the
tariffs about how this is Trump being
strong and this is going to hurt China
and bla bla bla bla bla
Fox News is strong Trump lackeys are
powerful in terms of the media presence
that they are given to show up and
recite their talking points and the
whole concept of being able to learn
about the world by watching the news has
been completely bastardized as it's been
taken over by partisan and corporate
interests and that's how you end up with
a headline that actually surprises
people like 100% of Trump's tariffs paid
by Americans we've been sounding the
alarm since day one that's the way
tariffs
work and the really shocking thing is
that so many people fell for it and by
the way Trump did this from day one
Trump from day one of his campaign are
very early on when he figured out that
this China trade stuff was beneficial to
him probably because his followers
didn't understand it so they would just
believe whatever he said he ran on I
understand trade
I understand economics I understand
currency manipulation I'm going to do
tariffs we're gonna deal with it all I'm
the guy I'll renegotiate trade deals and
all this stuff so he very successfully
and effectively primed his followers so
that then when he did whatever once he
was actually president they would just
think that it was good and I would not
be surprised you know when you talk to
trumpets and and you say what what does
Donald Trump have done that you really
like very often you get absolute
nonsense like nothing they don't they
can't even really say anything they just
say he's strong he's honest he's moral
he's a good businessman whatever there
are some who will actually be able to
put together some kind of policy and
they'll say I really like what he's done
with trade I really like what he's done
with the tariffs and of course they will
have absolutely no idea that they are
the ones paying for those tariffs it's
been very successful and whether or not
the mango Menace understands how tariffs
work it really doesn't matter as long as
his followers think he did the right
thing and it's helping them they will
vote to reelect him in November of 2020
what if I told you that you could read
eight books in one afternoon
that's essentially what one of my
favorite apps allows you to do it's
called blinka stand you can try it
totally free for a week and get 25% off
a subscription when you go to blink east
comm slash Pakman blink Asst takes
thousands of best-selling non-fiction
books gathers the most important info
and insights from each book presents
each book to you in the form of a
condensed ebook or audio book that you
can consume in just fifteen minutes
there are only so many hours in your
week blinka snakes it possible for you
to absorb the most valuable takeaways
from non-fiction books that you
otherwise might not have a chance to
read I just finished listening to catch
and kill by Ronan Farrow super injury
book probably already familiar to some
in my audience and a really interesting
take at how Harvey Weinstein and his
alleged transgressions were brought to
light excellent investigative piece you
can use blink Asst
to get through a topic quickly and
efficiently it's really useful if you
just want to explore a certain topic but
don't necessarily want to commit to
reading the entire book about whatever
it is and a premium subscription is only
about eight bucks a month which gives
you unlimited access to every single
book that they offer they have books on
politics economics philosophy science
you name it you can try it out yourself
totally free for a week and get 25% off
if you decide to subscribe just by going
to blink is comm slash Pakman I've put
the link right underneath this video
like the rest of us I bet you're going
into 2020 thinking about what you didn't
get around to in 2019 and your goals for
the new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you